my name's Gary Miller I come from Great
Britain it's fantastic to be in America
amongst the most positive people on the
planet I want to kick off this evening
by talking to you about body positivity
let's hear it for body positivity you're
absolutely right on a body positive
person I've always been a body positive
person unfortunately two months ago I
went to the doctor and he told me I was
dangerously close to being type two body
positive so let's sort that out I joined
a gym people in the gym keep trying to
make friends with me ladies and
gentlemen do not go up to somebody who
looks like me in a gym and try and make
friends with them we are not there to
make friends we are there because it is
a medical emergency going up to someone
who looks like me and a gym is like
going up to someone in an emergency room
who's got a vacuum cleaner stuffed up
their [ __ ]
hey man what are you here for I'm here
because I'm dedicated to pleasure
without a fully developed sense of
consequence I got a personal trainer
thought that helped me go he's a fun guy
he's full of Pappu's like hey man what
are your fitness goals I'd like to keep
my legs I need them to get to the fridge
I'm doing a fitness challenge with my
body rich Wilson we'll send each other
encouraging motivational picture
messages like like I'll send something
like I already been to the gym today and
done 10,000 steps you pie-faced sack of
[ __ ] you know just boys supporting boys
his his girlfriend and my wife asked if
they could get involved in the fitness
challenge and I said no it's just for
boys they said that's sexist I said yes
it is sexist but the sort of sexism
we're gonna leave exactly where it is
then what you mean by that I said some
prejudice you cannot fix
they said examples like I don't wanna
get served by a ginger guy in a Chinese
restaurant
that's not right sorry Conan I went to a
Chinese recently the chef was ginger I
didn't enjoy my dim sum
that's not ripe I'm not working I'm not
gonna leave it on the shelf my wife was
like how is this remotely similar and I
was like well men and women have made
great strides towards equality but I
cannot picture a world in the near or
distant future where I could text my
wife a picture of me doing that call her
up I face a Koosh it and it not be a
problem sometimes you got to leave some
mold on the cheese for flavor now my
best friend setters he moved to China
recently he came to see me this summer
he brought Kearny Connie's his fiance
she's from China she does not speak
English I do not speak Mandarin Sarah
speaks Mandarin fluently which is
ridiculous because he's always spoken in
a monotone okay a couple of you okay the
rest of you that's actually very funny
because Mandarin is a tonal language
okay it's a tonal language monotone dude
hahahaha
like I'm just saying if you were more
cultured get more out of this but I
can't do all the heavy lifting for you
okay
so we're having some friends round for a
barbecue we were in the garden I was
cleaning the barbecue they're having a
conversation which my near when a little
bit like this right Connie when she's
out chain cushion one okay everyone just
relax okay loosen your bar holes
okay I read on Twitter recently you
cannot discriminate against people who
are in a majority I've looked into this
there are loads of Chinese people okay
so if you're looking at this voice going
up that is not cool you're wrong and by
2019 Twitter rules not my rules
Twitter rules it's actually a brilliant
example of punching up and makes me a
bit of a hashtag hero so you're bloody
welcome she went she ain't got Xinhua
tour Bertram way barbecue woman Yoshi
chinois woman Yoshi BBQ BBQ BBQ no shima
Shinji BBQ she went huge somewhere BBQ
she would y'all barbecue that IgG child
BBQ she Lisi do it uh barbecue when by
when one chain may or tally odds on
round us away any reasonable person
would say in that situation what are you
talking about setter said
Connie's to start the social occasion
people are coming around four this
afternoon is called I said it's called a
barbecue she said cool what are we going
to be eating I said we're gonna be
eating barbecue
she went so the party is called barbecue
and the food is called barbecue when I
said yes barbecue she said okay cool
what's that thing called also know that
it's called a barbecue she said so
people are coming over for a barbecue
we're going to eat barbecue and it's
going to be cooked on a barbecue
I said yes that is what I have been
saying we are having a barbecue she said
that's the dumbest thing she's ever
heard white people make no sense and
they made me learn the mandarin to go on
this show right so I was just gonna do a
Chinese voice the producer was like no
there'll be complaints and I was like I
don't think a single Chinese person
would mind and he went not from Chinese
people I said from who he said whoa
quite liberals I said hang on it I have
to spend two months learning Mandarin so
I don't upset other white people when I
tell them a true story
that relies on neither I nor they
understanding a single word that's being
said with the exception of barbecue
he said that's exactly right so that's
the dumbest thing I've ever heard white
people make no sense
thanks guys chase